la tempête qui a balayé le nord de la
france ce week-end a tué 39 personnes et
fait 1 disparus selon un dernier bilan
communiqué par la sécurité civile
ce soir encore des dizaines de milliers
de foyers sont privés d'électricité
d'eau et de téléphone
partout on tente de réparer au plus vite
les dégâts
le point tout de suite avec dominique
dumas les arbres arrachés des toitures
effondrées des voitures éventrée c'est
le bilan matériel de cette tornade
historique
il faut maintenant revivre normalement
comme ici dans le calvados
difficile quand on sait qu'en dehors du
courant et du téléphone coupé les
canalisations d'eau sont hors d'usagé
dans ce département il est d'ailleurs
déconseillé de boire l'eau du robinet
mais c'est le bilan humain le plus
dramatique de son passage pendant
quelques heures de l'ouest vers l'est de
l'europe
au moins trente et une personnes ont
péri dans l'ensemble de ces départements
figurant sur la carte avec notamment
cinq victimes
en ille et vilaine pour l'île de france
sept personnes sont mortes et il suffit
de voir les arbres déracinés et les
échafaudages effondré pour imaginer la
force des rafales dans l'est
cinq départements ont déclenché le plan
orsec pour les cinq régions du grand est
on déplore 15 morts et 390 blessé
plusieurs personnes âgées ont péri
c'est donc maintenant la solidarité
envers les plus faibles qui doit jouer
comme ici en alsace dans cette résidence
pour retraités qu'il aura fallu évacuer
en tout cas tu verras que nous c'est
très dur un bon c'est sûr les gens ne
sont pas
préparer vraiment qu'est ce que vous
voulez les personnes âgées c'est pas
évident enfin pour un agriculteur de
d'ohnheim la perte est importante son
étable s'est effondrée ces 48 vaches
étaient prises au piège à un moment
donné on voyait le tout le toit qui
commençait à soulever qui se remettait
en classe c vers les midis 12h10
tout s'est écroulé d'un seul coup il y
avait un nuage de poussière énorme si
les principales liaisons comme ici dans
les vosges ont pu être rétablie
aujourd'hui il faudra rester vigilant
garder routes secondaires sont toujours
marrer par des arbres que ce soit
l'alsace où les autres régions touchées
par la tempête
le bilan matériel sera très longue